[Música]
[Aplausos]
cuando decidimos con mi pareja a tener a
mi primera hija yo imaginaba a ser un
papá muy presente atento y cariñoso el
modelo de padre con el que crecí estaba
muy encerrado en su trabajo con mucha
distancia emocional yo quería evitar
repetir esa historia con mi familia
durante el embarazo y los primeros meses
de vida yo me sentía en las nubes era
una felicidad inmensa
me cuesta poner en palabras lo fuertes
que son esas emociones sin embargo la
paternidad es mucho más compleja y
difícil de lo que me imaginaba
me encontré repitiendo lo que tanto
quería evitar yo me levantaba a las seis
de la mañana amigo a trabajar y hasta
las ocho de la noche no volvía a mi casa
llevaba muy agotado cansadísimo
y no me quedan energías ni ganas de
pasar tiempo con mi familia o de cuidar
a mi hija ella por momentos me veía como
un extraño y me costaba el doble que a
su madre cuidarla
recuerdo una vez que su mamá salió a
comprar algo a la esquina y me dejó al
cuidado de mi bebé que tenía apenas tres
meses
cuando su mamá salió y cerró la puerta
mi hija se despertó y se largó a llorar
con todos los pulmones no sabía qué
hacer la tomé en brazos y empecé a
pasearla pero no se calmaba
no sabía qué hacer salgo corriendo a
buscar a la mamá
sigo paseando live y calmará el momento
busco mi celular y pongo música
estaba muy perdido en ese momento me
sentí muy vulnerable muy impotente pero
sobre todo sentía mucho miedo
estas situaciones eran cotidianas y me
traían muchísimos conflictos con mi
pareja que sentía que no me podía dejar
al cuidado de mi hija
y entre el trabajo la crianza y esta
mala relación con ella era una sensación
de no dar más todo el tiempo
como psicólogo me puse a buscar
información y encontré que los expertos
dicen que lo que me pasaba era normal
lo único que necesita un bebé cachorro
humano es a su madre
algo de esto no me cerraba
así que con mi pareja decidimos buscar
ayuda
ella rápidamente encontró un grupo de
madres para acompañarse en estos cambios
tan bruscos que estaba experimentando
así que pensé que algo así podría haber
para mí me puse a buscar y a buscar pero
por mucho que buscara no existía no
había así que bueno arranque yo hice una
convocatoria en redes sociales subí un
flyer puse encuentro de padres de ahora
el lugar no tenía un lugar propio o
amplio así que decidí hacer una plaza y
ese día fui temprano llegaron dos padres
creo que era más fácil si los convocaba
a un asado a jugar fútbol va a tomar
algo
pero yo ese día me fui con una sonrisa
porque entendí que lo que me pasaba no
era algo único también estaba pasando a
otros así que no me desanime y continué
haciendo estos encuentros
y es que aunque no nos pase a todos la
paternidad
es un gran torbellino de emociones y una
crisis vital
los papás nos sentimos cansados
agobiados pero sobre todo nos sentimos
solos y frente a esta montaña rusa de
emociones
lo que hacemos es refugiar nos en lo que
ya conocemos
y lo que la sociedad nos ofrece
crecimos queriendo ser exitosos fuertes
independientes que hicimos jugando al
fútbol futbolistas jugando a la guerra
jugando a ser superhéroes todos modelos
de acción que nos marcan cómo debemos
ser como hombres
debemos saber aguantar en todo momento
y estos mandatos se sienten muchísimo en
la paternidad de hecho es una idea muy
positiva el de ser ese super papá para
tus hijos y para tu familia muchos
padres que me encontraban los encuentros
me decían
yo quiero darle lo mejor a mis hijos una
buena educación una buena cobertura de
salud no quiero que nada les falte y por
eso no paraban de trabajar
ahora en esta lógica faltaba algo muy
importante
faltaban ellos y su presencia en la casa
lamentablemente nos cuesta valorar tanto
el cuidado como el económico
y esta realidad se entiende cuando vemos
las políticas públicas hoy en día la
licencia por paternidad en la argentina
es de apenas 48 horas dos días alcanza
apenas para salir de la clínica con tu
hijo en brazos mucho menos va a alcanzar
para llevarlo a controles de salud o
para hacerle un dni
ya de entrada las políticas no nos
acompañan a pensar la paternidad de un
lugar diferente
pero sin embargo las políticas públicas
en sí mismas y por sí solas no son el
cambio de hecho un estudio en chile
demostró que más del 70 por ciento de
los hombres no se toman sus licencias y
casi un 40% no sabe ni de cuántos días
son
estos hombres elegían no estar en sus
casas porque entendían que su rol estaba
ligado al trabajo y no al cuidado
y yo me decidí a cambiar esa realidad
junto con diego pins un papá que me
encontré en esta misma búsqueda que yo
quisimos empezar a armar un espacio para
acompañar y ayudar a otros varones a
pensar su lugar les llamamos path
hernando
ahora bien cómo hacer para que la
paternidad sea algo diferente
primero lo que tenemos que hacer es
romper con esos mandatos de masculinidad
tan rígidos por suerte la paternidad
también puede ser un gran momento de
transformación es que durante los
primeros años de vida
y nuestras emociones están a flor de
piel
literalmente
un estudio demostró que los varones que
están cercanos y en proximidad con sus
recién nacidos experimentan un cambio
fisiológico y hormonal como el aumento
de la oxitocina de la vasopresina y de
la prolactina y una disminución de la
testosterona
estos cambios hormonales son los
responsables de sentirnos tan enamorados
de nuestros bebés recién nacidos
también está demostrado que los varones
que ejercen como cuidadores principales
de sus bebés experimentan una activación
cerebral igual a las de la madre
lamentablemente la organización del
cuidado recae casi siempre en las
mujeres y estos cambios físicos se
desvanecen
un papá me contaba que veo una licencia
extendida de dos meses él tenía que
volver a trabajar
durante esos meses él había podido
conectarse y vincularse muy cercano a su
hijo y sentía que volver a su trabajo
era dejar sola a su pareja y alejarse de
su hijo
así que luego de un tiempo él decidió
cambiar su trabajo para poder dedicarse
a la crianza a la par junto con su
pareja
esto era una renuncia muy grande a nivel
económico para él pero él lo vivió con
una oportunidad para vivir mucho más
plenamente su vida cotidiana
su rol nunca fue el de sostener a la
mamá sino el de cuidar de su hijo
y cuidar es un trabajo muy demandante
pero no quisimos ser padres para
trabajar más quisimos ser padres porque
teníamos un deseo de amor y de vínculo
sostener es diferente a cuidar
los padres podemos y debemos también
aprender a cuidar de nuestros hijos con
nuestras fallas y con estas actitudes
a partir del trabajo en paterna ando
acompañando a otros hombres me di cuenta
que aquellos que permanecían en los
grupos no solamente se volvían mejores
cuidadores de sus hijos sino que también
desarrollan mucho más la empatía esta
empatía reducía los conflictos en la
pareja y permitía una disminución en las
situaciones de violencia de género y una
mejora en torno a la equidad en la
pareja
estos cambios para nosotros también eran
muy grandes y eran muy notables porque
no solamente dejamos de sentirnos solos
y angustiados por no tener que hacer
todo sino que al mismo tiempo todas
estas emociones fuertes se volvían un
motor personal y ahora nos animamos a
cuidar de nuestros hijos desde el minuto
cero a hacerles upa a pasearles a bañar
les ayudarles a dormir
y en todos esos momentos nos sentimos
con miedo pero nos amigamos con ese
miedo y lo compartimos con otros desde
que comenzó mi travesía en paterna no
hemos acompañado a más de 800 hombres a
repensar su paternidad porque entendemos
que esta conversación que comenzamos
hace un tiempo tiene un poder de cambio
inmenso estos cambios son los que
posibilitan que ahora si las políticas
públicas se vuelvan muy necesarias y no
sólo licencias por paternidad sino
también seguros contra despido
permisos para poder ir a la reunión de
padres licencias para cuidar de nuestros
hijos cuando se enferman en casa y estos
son pasos importantísimos para una
igualdad de género
hace unos años
me encuentro viviendo la paternidad
diferente y esperando a mi segundo hijo
decidí hacer todo al revés
me animé a conectarme mucho más con mis
emociones
y eso está haciendo una experiencia
extraordinaria
no soy ahora el papá perfecto ni nunca
lo soy
pero me descubro en ternura
en capacidad de asombro en ganas de
jugar con mis hijos
y aprendí a contar con otros sin miedo a
equivocarme
por eso trabajo todos los días en
comunidades de papas porque veo en el
trabajo conjunto no solo la posibilidad
un cambio personal sino un cambio social
somos varones que demandamos ayuda y
necesitamos empezar a trabajar todos
juntos como sociedad para que los padres
dejemos de ser meros sostenes económicos
y no útiles para la crianza y podamos
ocupar un lugar como protagonistas del
cuidado muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]